blac chyna steps out looking like a
rainbow sherbert jeremy renner fractures
both his arms Blue Ivy freestyle raps on
her dad's new album while a bearded
Eminem spit some rhymes of his own he
does exist oh and its new music Friday
hey friends this is the daily Denny and
this might be the fastest we've ever
gotten to Friday lots of fun music stuff
for you guys today but let's get through
this robin china update now because as
predicted it's getting serious and
seriously juicy after a social-media war
was waged between her and her ex rob
kardashian Chyna stepped out on Thursday
rocking a new mystical look chives new
rainbow sherbert hair giving us unicorn
vibes and it all complimented her
matching rainbow Chanel bag of course it
did
an eye witness tells et Chyna was out in
LA for a photo shoot
smile for cameras and even snap selfies
with fans today might be a different
story though as we've learned the 29
year old has lawyered up since the
online blowout with Rob Chyna's lawyer
Lisa bloom tweeted that they will be in
court Monday seeking a restraining order
against Rob the day before bloom weighed
in on the nude pics and other claims Rob
made on social media saying that what he
did could be revenge porn and illegal
all I gotta say is Chris get in there do
something I'm going to be honest you
guys I don't have a good transition to
this next story so I'm just going to
tell you spider-man homecoming is out
today tweet me at D director after you
see it because I do want to know what
you thought I can't be the only one
geeking out over it and now of course
Tom Holland told me he went as far as
they would let him go on the stunts
before pulling in his double and I bet
his adventure Conrad Jeremy Renner is
wishing he did the same thing because
Jeremy aka Hawkeye apparently broke both
of his arms doing a stunt but here's the
ironic part it was a stunt and another
movie a comedy called tag that's right
the man who made his bones doing Mission
Impossible and Bourne movies and who has
starred and no fewer than four of the
aforementioned Marvel films chose a
low-impact comedy to render
him unable to sign autographs without
tremendous discomfort and you know what
that is really funny excellent timing
mr. Renner
seriously though that's a pretty tough
break see what I did there someone who
is stuntin on us at just five years old
is jay-z and beyonce daughter Blue Ivy
seems as though blue is already
preparing for her first Grammy because
she can be heard spin Rimes on a bonus
track from her dad's new album 444 so
first there was Hall and now there's B I
see I'm laughing because you know that
friend who was over-served and then all
of a sudden thinks they're Nicki Minaj
that is blue rapping but she does have
some rhythm and she's already building a
fan base fans online have already dubbed
themselves the Ivy League and can you
blame them blues giggling and talking
was already in Moms Beyonce's song blue
not to mention her heartbeat and cries
were featured in jay-z's 2012 single
glory we've got a star in the making
folks not that surprising all right now
someone who has been in the rap game for
a lot longer
mm we haven't really seen or heard from
the rapper in a minute but he's come
back looking grisly and reminding us why
he is the real Slim Shady and a special
birthday message to pal 50 cent who
turned 42 on Thursday yo v first off I
want to say happy birthday secondly I
want to remind you of the verse you did
that made me want to quit rapping
picture perfect picture picture me in a
pimp a picture me stylish it pictured me
busting my gat picture police mad day
and got a picture that picture me being
broke picture me smoking us dead picture
me coming up picture me rich from rat
pictured me blowing up now picture me
going back to my mama big fool and [ __ ]
picture that when promised the fact you
gotta watch your best you we're best
without a get you could talk and jet
hustle hard money jet fill it fill it
sell it pet so that get southern have a
bet 56 so much any benefit I'm out of
here
yeah so that made me want to stop rabid
for like a long time uh anyways man
happy birthday
let me homie peace okay I love that and
so did fifty so much in fact that he
posted to his Instagram and wrote thank
you mmm you know you're still the best
in the world to me man I love you bro
now you hear that Katie and Taylor where
is the love I'll tell you where it is it
is right here because it's Friday and as
always I've got three new Jam's for you
guys that I've already added to my
Spotify playlist are you ready to dance
because we're kicking things off with
Zedd the DJ producer scooped up one
Direction's Liam Payne for what Zetas
calling the soundtrack to summer and
it's called yeah girl oh yeah i'ma try
moving on to hiam aka our favorite girls
from the valley they just dropped their
second album something to tell you today
it's some easy breezy listening but the
song right Robbie bopping around the
office is kept me crying
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
ah back
[Applause]
I'm like channeling hime today with my
look tonight don't you think all right
and finally it's been four years since
we got a new LP from capital cities you
guys remember they're crazy and sexiest
song safe and sound well the dude got a
new banger and it's called
swimming pool summer
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh I am so glad those guys are back all
right well there you have it hope these
help kick-start your weekend tweeting
your thoughts at D direct oh and of
course subscribe to e t--'s youtube
channel because you know monday on daily
denne
we will be overflowing with more tea to
spill until then stick with each online
calm for a whole lot more enjoy your
weekend you guys bump us butter son